brazil is bracing for what could be its
deadliest month yet in the pandemic take
a look at the cemetery shown from the
air that is the scale of the
the disaster there u.s health officials
say the brazilian death toll
is expected to rise to nearly 3 500
per day it's driven by a dangerous
variant known as p1 that originated in
the country of brazil and that strain
has spread to the u.s and the cdc says
it is now our second most common
covet variant manuel bohorquez is in sao
paulo
brazil's largest city with a first hand
look manny good morning to you
good morning one of the reasons the
world is so concerned about what's
happening here in brazil
is the more the virus spreads the more
it can mutate as you mentioned it's
already
happened here with the p1 variant which
is believed to be more contagious
and in this country's most densely
populated areas
social distancing is practically
impossible
this is paraisopolis sao paulo's second
largest favela
the name given to sprawling low-income
neighborhoods often in the shadows of
wealthy enclaves
life was plenty tough here before the
pandemic
but the virus has amplified the poverty
a crippled economy means food insecurity
affects more than half of brazil's
population
antonio told me if he didn't accept
these community meals
he'd worry how he'd get money to eat he
did this
meaning robbing people would be the
other option
because there's no opportunity
in this worst moment i i'm trying to
give
the the best of myself to the other
people
marcus dusantos works for the non-profit
hands of maria that delivers about three
thousand lunches here
every day have a responsibility of the
government
that don't take care of the the people
so the government you feel has not taken
care of the people
here no president bolsonaro has been
criticized for blatantly ignoring
science and refusing calls for lockdowns
here in sao paulo some restrictions were
actually lifted on monday
allowing sports games to resume without
crowds and food pickup at bars and
restaurants
consider this last week one out of every
four coveted related deaths
worldwide happened here in brazil
cemetery workers now turn soil around
the clock
the burials are happening one right
after the other
in the short time we've been here we've
watched seven families
say goodbye to their loved ones and this
is their only chance to say goodbye
because funerals are not allowed
due to the pandemic lulu valpanosi heads
brazil's association
of funeral directors
he tells me kovitt has overwhelmed the
health care system
so even people who could get treatment
for heart disease
may not get it and unfortunately end up
becoming another death
it is pain compounded by fear that
things won't
soon get better brazil
is also facing troubles on the vaccine
front this month the health ministry
here cut its expectations for vaccine
deliveries in half
amid problems at both of the nation's
production labs
gail boy manuel thank you pain
compounded by fear never a good
combination in any situation thank you
very much